AVNISH MIDUTHURI: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome, and thank you
for joining this session
on Turbocharging App
Conversions with Android Pay.
I'm Avnish Miduthuri, a
product manager on Android Pay.
I'm joined here today by
Walter Cacau, software engineer
on the Android Pay team.
We're here to talk to
you today about the state
of in-app commerce and
some of the challenges
we see with in-app commerce
and how Android Pay can
help address some
of these challenges
for sales of physical goods
and services in your apps.
You'll hear from one
of our launch partners,
OpenTable, and how Android
Pay has enabled richer,
streamlined experiences
for their users outside
of a traditional checkout.
And finally, Walter's going to
walk you through the Android
Pay API's to show
you how easy it
is to add fast, streamlined
payments to your app
with just a few lines of code.
So to get started, I want to
talk about where we are today
with mobile commerce.
We've all heard about the
potential for mobile commerce
through the last few years.
But it's exciting that we're
now at this inflection point
where commerce is going
mobile first and leaving
online commerce in the dust.
That's not to say that
e-commerce isn't growing.
In fact, in the last year alone,
e-commerce grew at about 10%,
but m-commerce grew
at about 3x that rate.
And all that commerce
is happening in apps.
Over 64% of global
smartphone users
reported making a
purchase in apps.
The in-app commerce
is happening in a lot
of the traditional
shopping and retail apps
that you're familiar with on
the web, and a lot of that
is now moving to apps.
But increasingly, a
lot of in-app commerce
is being powered by innovative
platforms, on-demand services,
and marketplaces.
And you've all seen apps
in these categories.
They're disrupting
high-frequency, high-spend
categories like transportation,
food and grocery
delivery, hotel reservations,
hospitality, parking,
household services, and a
bunch of other categories
that I haven't listed here.
And you recognize some
of the top innovators
in each of these categories.
And all of these
apps, as it turns out,
have added Android Pay.
So that's the good news,
is that a lot of commerce
is now happening in apps.
But the not so great news
is that conversion is still
a huge, huge challenge.
And if you attended the
session today on mobile web
and how payment request
is solving that,
I think the problem is still
the same in apps as well.
It's the long
registration forms,
the long checkout forms
with over 15 steps
to add your full credit
card number, your CVC,
your expiration date,
your full billing address,
and if you're shipping
somewhere else,
your shipping address as well.
So it's not surprising
that over 55% of users
drop out of a mobile
checkout flow.
If you look at overall
card conversion,
it's even lower, lower
than 15% on mobile.
And a lot of apps
today are starting
to solve this problem
by creating sign ups,
getting people to sign
up for an account,
saving some of that information
so users don't have to enter it
again the next time.
But what's the
problem with that?
Remembering passwords.
Over 76% of users report
forgetting their passwords
and having to reset them
repeatedly by the way.
So how can we
solve this problem?
We think Android Pay can help.
You can let users check out your
app and check out as a guest
without having to sign up for
an account or use any password.
And that's because
users are already
signed into their Google
account on their Android device.
And with the Android Pay, when
they click a purchase button
in your app, they can
easily share their payment
and shipping
information with the app
with just a single click.
I'm going to demonstrate here.
Actually, this is Fancy, one
of my favorite shopping apps.
And one of the early developers
that added Android Pay.
Can you switch to
[INAUDIBLE] please?
I'm going to go to Fancy.
And there's this
nice Moscow mule mug
that I've been eyeing there
since I created that slide.
So I'm going to actually
try to buy it now.
There.
Just a single click.
And you'll notice how
quickly that UI surfaced up.
That's a native UI.
It's a new [? biflow. ?]
If you've actually
checked out Android
Pay in apps today,
it's a slightly
different [? biflow. ?]
But this is a new flow
we're going to be coming out
within a few weeks.
And again, as
developers, when we
make these product improvements,
you get them for free.
There's no
re-integration required.
So we'll be innovating
on the product
and improving
conversion over time.
And as developers, you'll
just get these benefits.
So I can actually authenticate
with my fingerprint here.
You'll see that the
information's passed back
to the app.
They've used the shipping.
Fancy's used the
shipping address
to calculate the
shipping amount here.
And if it looks good, I'm
going to go ahead and submit
the order.
And if my card actually gets
successfully approved here--
there we go.
So Fancy confirmed the order.
That's amazing.
And what you'll notice is
right as they charge my card,
there's also a notification from
Android Pay with the app logo.
And so your users will be taken
to an Android Pay [INAUDIBLE]
receipt here.
They can see that your app logo,
and they can open up your app
if you want to surface more
information about their order,
shipping times, et cetera.
So you see now Android Pay's
actually fast for users.
What that means for you
as developers is it's
going to really increase
conversion in your app.
And we've seen these
different results from Fancy,
for example, that reported
over 20% of their orders
coming in from Android
Pay and 2x the conversion
with Android Pay relative
to other payment methods
in their app.
Android Pay is also super easy
for developers to integrate.
Walter's going to walk you
through the API's in detail.
But just as a data point,
we hosted hackathons
for some of our
early developers,
and almost all developers were
able to integrate Android Pay
and add it, do an
end-to-end integration
with Android Pay in
just a few hours.
And finally, Android Pay
is more secure for everyone
in the ecosystem.
Secure for users
because they don't
have to hand out
their full credit card
numbers to merchants and
worry about merchants getting
breached.
The way we achieve
this is something
called payment tokenization.
So instead of returning the
user's actual credit card
number, we're generating
a virtual account number
when a user sets up Android Pay,
and that's the number that's
shared with merchant apps.
Along with that, you'll
also get a dynamic security
code that ensures that that
token can be used only once.
Merchants benefit from
the authentication
that we do on users.
Users authenticate and
set up a device analog,
including fingerprint
on supportive devices
like you saw there.
So you've heard from me about
the benefits of Android Pay,
but I wanted you to hear from
one of our close partners
and early launch
merchants, OpenTable.
And you may be
familiar with OpenTable
as a reservations
app, but I wanted
you to hear how they've
enabled rich commerce
experiences with Android Pay.
So I'd like to invite Mike
[INAUDIBLE] from OpenTable.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE: Thanks, Avnish.
On behalf of
OpenTable, we're really
excited to be part of Google
I/O. So for those of you
who don't know, OpenTable is
the world's leading provider
of online restaurant
reservations.
We seat roughly 19
million diners a month
across 37,000 restaurants
all over the world.
Since our date of
inception in 1998,
we've seated over a
billion diners globally.
What we enabled users to do
is search and find restaurants
based on their availability
and provide information
such as verified
user reviews, menus,
and other relevant restaurant
information up front
and allow them to easily book
through mobile apps and sites.
And as Avnish mentioned
before, alluded to,
we also support allowing
users to pay their check
through the mobile app.
And the goal of
payments was really
to improve that end
of meal experience.
Well, a typical
experience usually
starts with the end of the
meal, and you request a check
from your waiter.
Your waiter then goes
to the point of sales,
prints it out, and then
hands you the check.
And then you hand
your credit card over,
the credit card gets run,
brings the check back.
You have to do some mental math
quickly to calculate the tip,
and then you finally
sign the check.
And so with payments
on OpenTable,
we're really trying to
eliminate all those steps,
except for the last one.
So all you have to do
now is simply tap to pay.
So I think a lot
of you can kind of
relate with the
pain points we're
trying to solve with payments.
Particularly, for instance, if
you were planning a night out,
you have dinner and a
show or movie or meeting
up with friends.
And you've come to
the part of the night
where you've ended your
meal, and now you're
doing the dance trying to
get the waiter's attention.
You make eye contact.
You do the whole
signing thing in the air
just so you can
close out your bill.
So my team at OpenTable,
we kind of encountered
that similar situation where
we went out for a team lunch.
And you hear a lot of these
kind of situations where--
we went out for a team
lunch, and we kind of sort of
forgot our meeting at 1 o'clock.
And we were running late.
So we were able to
tell our waiter, hey.
We're going to pay
with OpenTable.
So you see all five of us
get up and walk out the door,
and we just simply
tapped to pay.
And that really makes that
seamless and streamlined
experience really relevant.
But as Avnish mentioned
before, getting set up
with Pay there are some
necessary evils like getting
our user set up
for payments, you
need to have a payment method.
So it typically involves
adding a credit card
number, expiry
date, CVC, zip code,
and we also ask
for a phone number
to verify your identification.
Which then we'll
send you a code.
And then once you're
verified, you're
finally set up for payments.
And as you can see, it involves
a pretty complicated process,
a lot of friction involved.
But with Android Pay,
you really eliminate
all of these kind of hiccups,
and the steps get set up.
So all you really have to do
is have your device set up
for Android Pay,
and we'll recognize
that you are properly set up.
And we'll automatically
set you up for payments.
So all you have to do
is make a reservation
and pretty much enjoy your meal.
At the end of your meal, you'll
get your check on your phone.
You'll be able to
choose a tip amount.
And don't worry.
We'll help you calculate it.
And all you have to do
is tap on Android Pay.
And as Avnish was
mentioning before,
you'll get a push notification
confirming that your card has
been charged.
And with the added bonus
of being in Android Pay,
you get to see this charge
along with all your Android Pay
transactions in the
Android Pay app.
So at OpenTable, we
really truly believe
that with payments when no
cash or cards exchange hands,
you're really free
to enjoy the moment.
And with that, I'd
like to hand it over
to Walter who will
walk you through how
to get your app set up.
[APPLAUSE]
WALTER CACAU: Thank you, Mike.
So now let's see how you can
add Android Pay to your app
in less than 20 minutes.
OK.
So first, let's go to our
overview of the Android Pay
API's that it will
need to call in order
to add Android Pay to your app.
Usually when the user goes
through checkout experience
using Android Pay, they will
go through three major steps.
The first one is they
will see the Android Pay
button or some option
to select Android Pay.
Then they will click that
option and be prompted by us
for a credit card and shipping
address if you request one.
And finally, when they are
ready to finish the purchase,
you can request a payment
credential from us
to charge the user.
OK.
So all these three
steps, they actually
map one-to-one to the
API that we show here.
The first API is
called isReadyToPay,
and it will return you a Boolean
indicating if the user has set
up Android Pay in that device.
And we highly recommend you to
optimize the user experience
in case we return
true in this API
because it will lead to a faster
checkout and overall better
experience.
Example of the
optimizations could
be you could make
the Android Pay
option be the default
one, especially
on guest checkout [INAUDIBLE].
Now, once you have shown the
Android Pay option and the user
has clicked, the next
step is to actually call
the loadMaskedWallet
API which will prompt
the user for their card
and the shipping address
they want to use.
And at the end, we'll return
you some masked information.
Now, the reason why we call
this masked information
is actually that it doesn't
contain the full payment
credential.
So you can't really charge the
user at that point in time,
but you have enough information
to render a review order
screen.
So you have something
for the card.
You'll see Visa 1234,
and you would also
have the shipping address.
So you can adjust the
card with sales tax
or provide the user with
different shipping option
depending on where
they live and so forth.
And finally, when they are
ready to finalize the purchase
and they have
confirmed their UI,
you can call the loadFullWallet
API here, the third one,
and get a payment
credential that you
can hand over to your
processor and charge the user.
OK.
Now let's get to some code.
So just want to note that
all the API's that we're
going to talk here,
they are already
part of the Google Play
services client library.
So you can start integrating
today if you want to.
Now let's talk
about the first API
that we mentioned, isReadyToPay.
So this API returns
a Boolean indicating
if the user has Android
Pay set up on that phone.
And it's just a simple API call.
You receive the result in
an asynchronous callback.
And once that result
comes through,
we highly recommend you to
optimize your experience just
like OpenTable and Fancy did.
Now, you know that you need to
show the Android Pay option.
So how can you show it?
We actually have
made it really easy
for you to add an Android
Pay buy button with something
that we call the WalletFragment.
So the WalletFragment is just
a regular Android fragment
that renders this nice looking
button that you see over here,
and there are some nice
advantage to using it.
So the first one is there's
actual Android Pay logo asset.
It ships with Google
Play services APK.
So it doesn't occupy
any space on your app,
and they are fairly
high resolution assets.
Also the button is
highly structural.
So it can fit a
variety of layouts.
And the Buy with text
there is translatable.
So if you have a user
in a Spanish locale,
they will actually see
this text translated.
And also, it contains
default click listeners.
So when the user
clicks on this button,
it will do the load
masked quality API
that we talked about for you.
So overall, it would just
make your integration simpler,
and we highly
recommend you to use it
if your flow has a
checkout button like this.
Now, we know there are several
kinds of purchase experiences
over there.
So if your checkout doesn't have
a checkout button like this,
you are free to call the
loadMaskedWallet API yourself.
But if you're using
a button like this,
we highly recommend you
to use the WalletFragment.
OK.
So now how you use
the WalletFragment?
It's basically
three simple steps.
The first one, as
you can see here,
is to create the WalletFragment.
The second one is
to initialize it
with the masked caller request.
So it can call the load masked
quality API on your behalf
and prompt the user for the
card and shipping information.
And the last step is to
add it to your layout
as you would add any other
fragment through fragment
manager and a
fragment transaction.
OK.
So let's dive a little deeper
on the masked caller request.
So the masked caller request
contains several parameters
that can be used to
customize our flow
to the needs of your app.
The only three required
ones are the ones
shown here in the screen.
The first one is
the currency code.
The second one is the
estimated total price.
And the third one is the
tokenization parameters.
Now, tokenization parameters
are an interesting kind
of parameter.
So they actually specify how we
receive the payment credential
at the end of your flow.
There are two ways that
you can receive a payment
credential with Android Pay.
The first one, if you are
already using vaulting services
from Stripe, Braintree,
or [? Venta, ?]
you can actually have us vault
the payment credential for you
and return you a
vaulted token that you
would charge any other vaultage
credential with these services.
But there is a second way that
is the one actually showed here
in the slides where you
can receive the payment
credential directly in an
encrypted form with a key
that you specify in the
tokenization parameters.
Later on, you will
need to decrypt or send
to one of our
supported processors
for doing the decryption
for you and charge the user.
But we'll get to that later on.
Now, besides these three
required parameters,
there are also some
optional parameters
that you can use to
customize our flow
to meet the needs of your app.
So you can request shipping.
You can say if you
need a phone number.
You can have us actually
filter out the cards
that you don't support.
For example, if you don't
support prepaid cards,
you can specify in the request.
And this provides a highly
customizable UI for your flow.
OK.
Now let's just recap.
The user has saw the
Android Pay button.
They have clicked on it.
They have selected a card
and a shipping address.
And they are finally ready to
commit and finish the purchase.
So what's the next step?
It's actually to
charge the user.
And to do that, you need
to request a payment
credential from us.
And to do that, you call our
last API called Full Wallet,
and to call that
API, you need what
we call the FullWalletRequest.
The FullWalletRequest is
this nice little object here
that receives only two
parameters basically.
The first one is the
Google transaction
ID, which is just
an identifier that
is generated by
the previous call,
and you just need to forward
it to the second call
to be able to complete it.
And the second one is the card
containing the total price
in the currency code.
Now, once you called Full
Wallet in the last line here,
when the result
is ready for you,
it will be delivered through
the onActivityResult callback
in your activity,
and you can just
check the request code
that you passed in the call
and extract the Full Wallet
out of the [INAUDIBLE].
And finally, out
of the Full Wallet,
you can get the payment
token that you can later
send to your processor
for charging the user.
Now, let's just
dive a little deeper
on what the payment token
actually looks like.
So the payment
token, in the case
where you receive the payment
credential directly encrypted,
is just this nice
little JSON blob
containing a bunch of keys
related to our encryption
scheme.
Not all that interesting.
But there are some
interesting things
to be said actually about
the decryptive response
that you can see
in the next slide.
So there are actually two
fields here that I would like
you guys to pay attention to.
The first one is the dpan.
The second one is
the 3dsCryptogram.
So dpan, it actually stands for
device personal account number.
And as you can see, it
looks like a credit card,
but it's not really
a credit card.
It even passes the
[INAUDIBLE] as a curiosity.
Now, when a user adds a card
to Android Pay, the payment
networks and the
insurers, they generate
this number called the
dpan, and that gets
associated with your phone.
And that's actually
what gets charged.
And this number has
pretty much no relation
with the real user's
credit card number,
which provides
some nice security
properties of Android Pay.
For example, if you
lose your phone,
there is no need for
you to reissue your card
and cancel your previous card
because your credit card number
was not compromised at all.
Now, the other interesting
field is the 3dsCryptogram,
which is basically a replacement
for the traditional CV
that you see in the
back of your card.
It's a dynamically
generated security code,
and we use it to provide
this nice second property
about the Android Pay security
model, which is-- this payment
credential that you see here
can only be charged once.
And this is a huge advantage
compared to a normal credit
card because if you lose
your credit card number,
it can just be charged
multiple times.
OK.
Now, we have talked
about how you
can call the API's and how you
receive this encrypted token.
Now, you can decrypt
the token yourself,
but we highly
recommend you to use
the service of all our
supported processors.
They will take care of
generating the keys,
managing the keys, and doing
the decryption for you.
So I highly recommend you
to check their documentation
because they will just
make your life easier.
Now I'm going to hand
over and turn it over
to Avnish for him to complete.
Thank you, everybody.
AVNISH MIDUTHURI:
Thank you, Walter.
[APPLAUSE]
As Walter said, you can actually
work with any of these payment
providers.
Come see us if you don't see
your payment provider listed
here, and we can tell you how to
actually get Android Pay set up
on your app and going.
So the last few months, we've
worked with several merchants
to onboard Android
Pay in their apps
and see how the
evaluation looks.
And we're now
excited to announce
that Android Pay's
available to all developers
selling physical goods and
services in all the markets
that Android Pay supported.
We've launched in the
US, and we recently
announced that we've
launched in the UK as well.
We're coming soon to
Australia and Singapore.
So again, we're excited
to have developers
add Android Pay to their app.
You can check out Android Pay
and any of these select apps
that have added Android
Pay to see how they've
created better experiences,
better checkouts,
for their users.
In terms of what's
next, if you haven't
had a chance to actually
go see the live code labs,
you can actually go to
the online code labs here.
We also have fully documented
developers on Google.com.
So check out our documentation.
Comes see us right
after this session
as well if you
have any questions.
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]